vice president kamala harris is now
hitting back at questions on why she has
to even visit the southern border
as it's now been 77 days since the
president named her as the point person
on the crisis
the vice president suggesting the real
focus should not be on our border but
instead on what's going on in places
like guatemala and mexico
watch can you commit right now
that you will indeed visit the u.s
mexico border and will you do it soon
jeremy let me tell you something yes i
will and i have before
but the reality of it is that we need to
prioritize what's happening at the
border and we have to prioritize
why people are going to the border i
think it's short-sighted
for any of us who are in the business of
problem solving
to suggest we're only going to respond
to the reaction as opposed to
addressing the cause but the vice
president is not yet providing dates on
a potential visit
do you plan to visit the border
um not today
but i have before and i'm sure i will
again madam vice president
there have been questions about why you
and president biden have yet to visit
the border the u.s southern border and
i'm wondering if you can answer some of
those
the reason i am here in guatemala as my
first trip
as vice president of the united states
is because this is one of our highest
priorities and i came here to be here on
the ground
to speak with the leader of this nation
around what we can do
in a way that is significant and i will
continue to be focused
on that kind of work as opposed to grand
gestures
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole
this whole this whole thing about the
border we've been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
i'm not discounting the importance of
the border
oh tommy here we see her getting just
more and more defensive by the day
digging in about why she doesn't have to
go to the southern border
as vice president you know it's bad when
someone from the leftist mainstream
media even has to ask the question
because we know that generally they
don't like to do that but it's gotten so
bad she's going to have to address it
but kamala
said i want to go back to the reporting
and talking about you know the 75 year
old grandmother that's coming across
nobody watches that and doesn't feel for
that woman and the others that are
coming over
but i'd also like to say a couple of
points here she's coming from venezuela
i believe this is also
you know a warning to those of us in
this country what happens when you let
your nation be taken over
by socialists and you let communism and
socialism come into your nation then you
have to flee
from it and i've said this before and
i'll say it again nobody flees from the
united states but many people flee to it
so that's just
again another reminder in talking about
this border crisis but it's not enough
for kamala to say do not come
when you're incentivizing people to come
over here when they're promising them
health care
when you're promising them that they
will essentially be caught and released
when you're giving them stimulus checks
in some places
they are going to continue to come over
here whether you have a half-hearted
response saying do not come or not
they are going to continue to come over
and as i say every time
i am on the show and every time we talk
about these so-called root causes
that kamala went on her two-day little
photo op escapade to discover
when you allow an open border you are
funding the very criminal organizations
that are destroying these nations that
people are fleeing from
when you have an open border you're not
only destroying our nation through mass
illegal immigration but you're also
funding the organizations that are
ruining those so at the end of the day
we need to secure our border not only
for our country
but for those countries as well so they
can get back on track the criminal
organizations are not being funded the
way they are now because of this
wonderful
criminal enterprise that we're providing
want to know the root causes kamala you
didn't have to go to guatemala to find
them
you could just take a look at our
southern border and have a little common
sense
that's exactly right and leo so you saw
the vice president there in guatemala
saying
you know my physical presence here
denotes the priority this sends the
message of how much i prioritize
my work with you but as tommy points out
then that also equally sends the message
that her absence
at the southern border certainly sends
the message that it's not a priority
and again establishing a meaningful
border so that because right now the
open border
it's not compassionate it is simply
cruel so she's ignoring the root cause
that comes from her own administration
leo
you're absolutely right and let's let's
just be honest you know i'm listening to
her
as a lawyer what did she accomplish by
going to guatemala and mexico
nothing it was nothing more than a photo
op and she got destroyed she got
destroyed and annihilated by the
reporter
she accomplished absolutely nothing when
she talks about the root cause
this country is not in the nation
building guatemala or mexico
we had a secure border on january 19
2021 it has been let loose by the biden
harris administration
let's just talk about the elephant in
the room
kamala harris is over her head she
doesn't want to be there
she doesn't want to be there at all she
was forced to go there
primarily from fox news conservative
outlets constantly
showing the situation at the southern
border what is her end game
kamala i'll tell you right now you have
no political future that
you just have no political future and
this will haunt her
and the problem is simply this when she
can become sarcastic
and show that nervous laugh which is a
defensive
posture of her inability to handle this
issue
it comes across over and over again and
if she's getting her march he orders
from the left
ocasio cortez she's in trouble the
bottom line is this
let's be very clear the biden harris
administration
has no game plan for the southern border
she wants america to ignore it we will
never
ignore the southern border combler
harris
that's exactly right leo and especially
in conjunction with for example one of
her tasks which is in charge of
voting rights where she came after
minutes after the president named her in
that role she came out with a statement
and remember the first statement she
ever made on the border was days later
when pressed by a reporter so
to your point it's exactly it's so clear
how much she hates this job and that she
is in fact
overwhelmed and kaylee there was one
reporter however that didn't destroy her
i'm going to show you a video
when uh univision reporter maria
fernanda it was allegedly her
asked a question but it ended up not
being her it ended up being
just a fan girl watch this moment here
we'll get your reaction on the other
side
our next question will come from maria
fernanda
at univision thank you madam vice
president
for me it's an honor because i actually
got to vote for the first time
as a nationalized citizen and i voted
for you
yeah it's remarkable emily that pretty
much sums up the trip uh
that was not a real reporter they're
looking into it but this trip went
horribly i mean to echo leo's points
it's not just
my friend leo saying that this is going
to haunt her
in fact democrat operatives have told
the hill on background so on the
condition of anonymity
uh that this trip is going to haunt her
uh they said you know who wants the
border on their list of
uh political duties because it's a it's
a hot button issue it's one that's very
hard to solve and especially when you're
making all the wrong decisions but
when you have aoc coming out and
criticizing her she's now lost her
friends on the far
left only 45 of americans approve of the
way joe biden is handling the border so
she's losing moderates
in the process as well and now the white
house has even come out apparently white
house insiders
i saw this on cnn this morning told cnn
this
we are stunned by kamala harris's
inability to answer a question
so democrats are calling her out white
house insiders are calling her out
she's got a lot of problems on her hands
and then the voting rights
uh the voting rights mission as well was
tanked by joe manchin
she is failing miserably at each of the
tasks that i've been given to her
harris your thoughts you know uh part of
this conversation was about how
some of the mainstream media lester holt
and others are forced to kind of
acknowledge the the 800 pound gorilla in
the room
and i'm looking at a report from colby
hall uh who's a media writer and
and he says did you see what what cnn
did
white house perplexed by kamala harris
performance on first foreign policy this
coming from cnn's jeremy diamond
unnamed white house insiders were left
perplexed by the performance of vice
president harris on her recent trip to
guatemala and mexico
remember when she started she said
jeremy let me tell you something she was
kind of tough with him because she knew
the questions were coming and he was
already in the middle of it
i mean it's it's got to be uncomfortable
now because you're you're caught between
a rock and a hard place you mentioned
aoc is taking her to task
right the progressive's not happy so i
don't know if she's listening to them or
not doesn't sound like she is
and then the president puts her in in
charge of something that's going to be a
political powder keg for her if she does
want to go forward so leo you're right
i mean if this is the lily pad she has
to stand on to get to the presidency
next round or whatever
i hope she can swim but when you look at
when you look at what's really really
being said and done so she goes down
there she talks to the leaders of
guatemala and
mexico and her single message coming
back is
don't come so she's not listening to the
president's policies which
don't say that either what is going on
with the vice president it is time to
ask that question
and she better have an answer quickly i
don't care how many cookies she carries
with her
and she talks about going to the
southern border would be a just a grand
gesture but i think
we americans call that showing up but
but emily just real quickly the part of
the border she went to and and
as a senator was in your former home
state of california
they have a wall yeah all right i'm done
i went on brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now